and finally new rule three months into
his presidency it's time to admit that
joe biden
has been a huge disappointment to
comedians
all the jokes we were stockpiling about
ancient daughtering sleepy joe
useless the man has been nothing short
of sharp
focused and completely on top of things
we were expecting a font of
comedy gold about a senile geezer
showing up to work in his pajama bottoms
and
plowing his motorcade into a farmer's
market
[Laughter]
forget the dog he was gonna bite someone
on the south lawn
but a funny thing happened on the way to
the old age home biden slayed the orange
dragon and
is now spearheading the most
transformative administration since
fdr with an approval rating of 59
percent
even the joe biden ticks and gaffes that
used to bug us
the hair smelling and the getting lost
in a sentence and the
challenging of random people to a fight
in the parking lot
gone gone biden stepped up his game
yes he got better at 78. what a
mind-blowing concept that must be to the
younger generations for whom writing
someone off simply for their age
is the last acceptable prejudice
oh yes
they hate every ism except ageism
it's completely forbidden to tell any
joke about race gender religion
weight but age have at it
you ever go down the greeting card aisle
at cvs every card for anyone over 60 is
the same joke
happy birthday i'm surprised your dick
hasn't fallen off
now the ex the excuse for this prejudice
has always been well we're a young
country
i've been hearing that my whole life
america is a young country well
tonight i'd just like to say this
america
you're not that young anymore powdered
wigs was a long time ago
it's time you grew up it's time to stop
doing
stupid teenage immature things and
number one on that list is not getting
the most fundamental trade-off in life
you're beautiful when you're young wise
when you're old
this is
this is the only country in the world
dumb enough
not to get this most basic intuitive
obvious
violent underdog concept
[Music]
that if as they say you learn something
new every day
it stands to reason someone who's logged
10 000 more days is going to be in
general a little wiser
life is a series of patterns you don't
see it at first
because it's not a pattern yet but by
the third
time yeah okay i get it now yes
societies need youthful energy and fresh
eyes on problems and it's true
it takes young people to start a
revolution
but biden is the right man for this
moment precisely because he
is old been there done that
to virtue he's getting things done
on wealth inequality in afghanistan and
racial justice and climate change that
keyboard warriors only dream about while
muttering okay boomer
[Laughter]
young dumb and full of calm yes
there is a season for that
but right now i'll take old stooped and
full of soup
and yet instead of finding biden's age
an asset
in america it was his biggest obstacle
in the run-up to the last election
37 percent of americans were unabashed
about telling pollsters they flat out
wouldn't vote for someone over 70.
is there anything more piss-ignorant
than not using old people as a resource
not taking advantage of their
accumulated knowledge
everywhere else in the world elders are
sought for guidance
in america elders are sought for
tick-tock pranks
in greece old man is a compliment not
something you scream after get out of my
way
in india young people touch old people's
feet to show reverence
japan has a national holiday called
keronuhi
respect for the aged day you know the
reason why advertisers in this country
love the 18 to 34 demographic
because it's the most gullible yeah
a third of people under 35 say they're
in favor of abolishing the police
not defunding but doing away with a
police force altogether
which is less of a policy position and
more of a leg tattoo
36 of millennials think it might be a
good idea to try
communism but much of the world did try
it
i know millennials think that doesn't
count because they weren't alive when it
happened
but it did happen and there are people
around who remember it
pining for communism is like pining for
betamax or myspace
so when you say you're old you don't get
it get what
abolish the police and the border patrol
and capitalism
and cancel lincoln no i get it the
problem isn't that i don't get what
you're saying or that i'm old
the problem is that your ideas are
stupid
if you say let's eat in the bathroom and
[ __ ] in the kitchen
yeah that's a new idea
but i wouldn't call it interior design
you think someone 80 is hopeless because
they can't use an iphone
maybe the one who's hopeless is the one
who can't stop using it think i'm out of
it because i'm not on twitch
well maybe i get twitch but i just think
people watching
other people play video games is a waste
of [ __ ] time
20 of gen z agree with the statement
society would be better off if all
property was owned by the public and
managed by the government
and another 29 say they don't know if
that's a good idea
here's who does know anyone who wasn't
born yesterday
you